so our next speaker not yet a PhD
Dropout was actually voted by all this
phg classmates as the person they would
most want to be stuck with on a stranded
desert
island yes uh please welcome Dusty um
this isn't my focus on what I'm studying
but it is a kind of a side project I did
when I first got there working in the
Consulting lab um I should note the fun
fact whatever Jared said about how my
PhD cohort they voted me as the one that
they would most like to be stranded on a
desert island with I was super uh super
happy that they voted me that you know
I'm thinking like oh what a nice
popularity contest if you're stuck
one-on-one with somebody like on a
desert island for I don't know years
like they'd want to be with me how nice
but I I found out it's mostly because
you know I have this Army background and
they think that I would help them
survive the longest so not quite the
compliment that I thought it was and
speaking of that I have the results uh
in a pie chart uh nonetheless um so I'm
going to win several tties today and
this fly is going to join me several
tties um because I have a number of pie
charts um some graphs not well explained
so we'll critique it all all at once and
I feel like I can't look this way I have
to look that way um I'll probably be
looking this way the most maybe I'll
change the side of the mic while I talk
um there we go maybe how about that okay
uh I was also um flattered uh that they
thought I would be the first person to
die among the cohort um but it's mostly
because I'm about twice the age of most
of the people that I'm with um they're
they're closer in age to my my children
than they are to me um so it's certainly
an eye opener when that happens um I'm
also got one vote for most likely to be
arrested so I don't really know what to
make of that I'm I'm the red one here
you know I could get a dunde for
confusing me for not a dunde uh a tough
d
uh office fans I'm glad the generation
hasn't passed enough that we don't know
what the office is um but maybe the most
concerning is that I have quite a few
votes for most likely to get a non-
statistics job and uh it probably
doesn't bode too well with the rest of
my talk that we have going on that they
don't have that much uh confidence in me
so uh with that being said
um I'm to talk about um a little bit of
a little bit of military leadership and
world leadership so we all know that
these four uh people up here are
presidents but what else do they have in
common good guess they all have military
service um we we know Grant um from his
Fame during the Civil War um Kennedy was
in the Navy President Nixon was also in
the Navy and Bush the first uh spent
some time in the Army Air Corp um the
question we're going to try to answer
through some analysis
is does the military service of world
leaders influence them when uh they're
in charge and they have the choice of
whether to involve their nation in a uh
militarized dispute now I'm bringing up
a very touchy subject I recognize that I
wear a uniform I'm in the Army um what
I'm talking about today has nothing to
do with me being in the Army this is not
reflect Army policy nothing so I don't
want to end up on the New York Times or
Bloomberg or anything like that because
of uh the results I I present here um so
what you should be thinking is uh how
did you get involved in in doing this
research so I should explain for a
second before I jump into it all that
yes I am at a PhD program at Baylor I
started uh my time in the Army as an
engineer officer about the 10e point I
transitioned into to doing operations
research uh it has led me uh to degrees
at Ohio State and also to uh teaching at
West point I'm scheduled to go back to
West Point uh after the PHD program that
is the reason I'm at at Baylor right now
doing this so uh there you have it oh I
also don't have I didn't use leaplet I'm
sorry Jared um I use GG map but the
reason I use ggmap is because one of my
advisers uh on my dissertation I don't
know if you know Dr kale he's the author
of ggap he's quite a talented
statistician and AR coder um Google him
sometime he's a really impressive man uh
speaking of impressive people Dr ceran
my other adviser um while I've known him
from being in the military and having
served with him in different locations
uh he is a local Waco celebrity as he's
participating on Dancing with the Waco
Stars so uh he Rivals chip gains maybe
for Waco fame
um but Dr Campbell approached the
statistical Consulting department at
Baylor and he's a political scientist
and he's asking us this question to help
inform some of his research is what we
just talked about our leaders with
military experience like does what
impact does that have on um you know
whether or not their countries are in
militarized dispute I'm going to go
through this process give conclusions
and then I'm going to hedge a little bit
so just have that in the back of your
mind uh as I go through all this um what
he brought with him uh when he was
asking us to do this research was the
lead data set as you can see lead stands
for leader experience and few
descriptions essentially dating back to
the the
1800s um it has information about every
world leader from information about
their family their work life their uh
political background the type of country
that they're in uh in the nature of
their military service if they had any
and there's also an indicator variable
that that is our our variable of
interest of whether or not their country
was involved in a um armed conflict or
military dispute is the official term
while they were in office um they could
have taken over that office um at the
time of the dispute like they could have
already been in the dispute and that
would count for them um so this isn't
necessarily causal um so that like I'm
saying should be in the back of
everyone's mind all right so as I'm
talking to you about this I'm assuming
several things um one of those is that
you have a little statistics background
I'm going to talk to you as a if you
understand things like uh log odds odds
ratios uh P values things like that um
secondly I'm going to talk to you as if
you have a little r background I assume
everyone does or is at least very
passionate about that or we wouldn't be
here and then lastly um you might not
have showed up here interested but maybe
you're interested in the uh you know the
real world question whether these
people's service impacted any of their
uh you know their decisions um when they
were presidents of the United States and
I should just note now I'm showing only
US presidents but this is at large uh
throughout world leaders of of the
entire Globe um all right so back to the
main point let's actually start talking
at the data um so toughy award number
one uh what I'm showing here I guess
number five this is the fifth chart I've
got up uh is a stack bar chart using
Baylor colors go sick on Bears of each
factor relat to their military
background so were they in combat or not
yes or no and the percentage of those uh
individuals who were involved in a
military dispute versus those who didn't
so you can see if you didn't you because
the green bar gets larger you are more
likely to have been in a military
dispute when you were the leader of the
country uh according to to this we're
going to look at the the interactions
behind all this in a little bit and the
same is true if you served in a career
and also military non-combat and some of
you who have done some model building
exercises before you're probably already
jumping up and down saying oh these
things relate so much there's
interactions you're you're right and I'm
spilling water on myself so I'm just
going to set this down here so I don't
do that again I got excited um so we
want to take a look at that uh as a part
of this and we will do that but before
we do let's look at some of the factors
that might influence this uh one of
those might be um the years in office or
the years in politics um it does appear
and I've also taken the log because to
the trained eye you can tell this is
already skewed data and even the log is
skewed but um those who um let's see
let's look at years in office the median
um years in office uh when the longer a
person is in office the more likely it
appears that they get their uh their
country happens to be in a military uh
dispute um we can see the opposite of
that is true with years in politics and
also when it comes to age the older you
are it appears on average the more
likely uh you are to uh get your company
company country in a military I hope
your company's not a military dispute
but some might say that's the the case
around around here um okay back to these
Baylor bar charts here's some more
factors you can see a couple things one
um if you have a creative side to you
like this is part of you were part of
Arts uh before you got into politics
before you became a world leader um you
were more likely uh to be involved in a
military dispute less likely if you were
considered an illegitimate child um
medicine you can see is about 50/50 and
I'll let you uh just kind of ingest the
rest of that while I go on to the next
you now I'm only showing you six seven
eight nine factors there was about 70 or
80 factors that we considered uh in this
and speaking of of how to consider all
of these um if you've been in a you know
statistics 101 class you've probably
done some model building exercises like
forward selection or backwards selection
there's inherent problems with all of
these because what happens when you to
do multiple hypothesis tests you get
into all sorts of false positives and
all the things that's kind of the
downside of some of these factors Dr
Sturdivant who I mentioned before wrote
a book called applied logistic
regression where he introduces
purposeful selection that tries its best
to get around that and what purposeful
selection does is it is a seven-step
process where you look Univar at at
every factor in the model and you do a
ton of steps some of them iteratively
and you eventually get a final model and
you look at interactions and you've uh
you've tried to to get all the
intricacies I'm not going to go through
every step here but I'm going to focus
maybe on three of them here as we go
through uh the rest of this process
and the first thing I did um because it
wasn't really built out in any any uh
any package was I Built My Own function
to look univariately at every Factor
versus whether or not the leader was in
a military dispute during their time and
I did this in the following way um I
built a oops I didn't want to go that
way there you go I built a function that
takes factor and then it builds a
formula CW and it was the indicator
variable
um that would create this formula and
then do our standard logistic regression
um that um most of us are probably
familiar with and then it did a lot of
cleaning of the data and then it would
output um a little table here with uh
you know if the factor was age you can
see that age has a slightly positive
influence um with a very small P value
so univariately we would conclude that
age is an impact maybe the older you are
the less you care about the rest of your
life I don't know what to make of that
um but when we look at this for all the
factors of interest um I just mapped
over this it took about 2 minutes um
which is frustratingly slow for 70 uh
factors um we end up with this data and
you can see Univar a lot of factors are
significant so what we ultimately do is
we'll take all these into our first like
preliminary effects model where we want
to start testing interactions and
iterally removing uh insignificant
factors um we draw a line eventually it
looks like I drew the line right about
here uh at 01 .1 uh P value and we
didn't consider the rest of those for
for the rest of this analysis um I'm not
going to go through each step because it
was quite tedious um but earlier I
eluded that there might be some sort of
relationship like what if somebody was a
uh you know had a was in combat and a
career in the military those two might
have some sort of like multiplicative
effect or what if you know somebody was
um you know in combat but not a military
career you know when you build a model
in R you can create all these indicator
variables but I wanted to be a little
more specific about it so I created my
own variable that combined these three
handling all of these uh factors uh
together and as terrible and as
mind-numbing as it is I labeled in
000000001 Z like it's awful but that's
why I have this little chart here to
help us understand what I did and you'll
notice that these are mutually exclusive
you can't have been in combat and been
in the military but not went to combat
does that make sense so that's why those
don't overlap
um when we slowly get down to the final
uh model we'll get to the punchline
where we can see the impacts of the
variable ADV interestes and it does
appear as such that each one of these uh
with the experience of one1 which who
knows what that means I I'll pull up a
chart in a second of one1 you do have a
slightly positive uh effect on whether
or not your country will be in a
military dispute while that person is is
a leader now I've done my best to help
us see these impacts in the next chart
so don't a ward me upfront with with the
the toughy oh that's not it that's the
sorry I I'm ahead of myself this is uh
Jared's favorite coof plot or at least a
version of it where we can look at the
uncertainty on each of these and you can
see the wide range we have on each one
of our factors but the interesting one I
want to talk about is is this what I've
done here is I've split I've faceted out
the types of experience that all of our
presidents have had in the top left are
just the presidents who've got no
military experience
whatsoever on the top right these are
the presidents that were both in combat
and had a entire career in the military
these are the presidents who uh were in
combat but did not have a career in the
military and these are the presidents
who were in the military but didn't have
a didn't end up in combat but also um
didn't serve an entire career all right
now the second thing to look at is the
green or the the blue dot for each one
of these people is their
coefficient or the prediction of whether
or not uh they would have taken their
country to War uh with all their other
factors so we showed some before like
were they a doctor what was their
background this is their prediction and
then the Green Dot is once you add in
the coefficient the impact of their
military experience that they have so
you can see some of these presidents
went from Truman oh not so much Truman
he definitely let our country in war
right so he's over here um the reason
there's no line uh with these
individuals is because
um
they were not that's the Baseline Factor
um there was no uh like addition it was
part of the intercept um so we can see
that these factors do have some type of
influence uh on aggregate over whether
or not their country would would be at
war or I don't want to say at War but it
would be in a milit militarized conflict
while they were in charge um what else
is interesting um we might be interested
in some of the outliers uh the logistic
DX package is a great package for uh
bringing up a number of outliers such as
Delta beta hat and just to give an idea
what this might be beta hat is the
coefficient for for that individ or for
um for the factor of Interest the idea
is if they were removed from the data
set what would the change be to Beta hat
that's the idea behind most of these um
these metrics and terrible to look at I
know it looks like a constellation we
could all um you know imagine that this
is what the night sky looks like um I
bring to uh you know your attention some
of the people that we looked at before
uh the initial ones um they don't seem
to be outliers there were a few who I
believe uh every indicator said that
they wouldn't go to war but their
country was or every indicator said they
would be at War and their country wasn't
um so that's why we have some some
outliers like that uh other things to
note I I what I don't want to do is is
end up uh like I said on New York Times
it's why Jared usually asks me or those
who are in the military when they when
they present to be in uniform I said
Jared I can't be here uh a guy in the
Army talking about how we might all be
potential warmongers that is not at all
what I'm saying at all so and I didn't
want it to look as if an army guy was
saying it what I am saying though is as
we look through the data there were
certainly some things you could debate
about like what is a military
militarized dispute like what is a
conflict um so I didn't assemble the
data I'm not throwing my hands up but
what I am saying is some things are are
up for debate uh on how we would uh
categorize some of these factors other
things is there's certainly uh we can't
draw causality of this we can't say that
because a president or a world leader is
uh has a military experience that they
are more likely to have their their
country at War because oftentimes one
might think if we are at War we might
want to elect a president with some type
of military experience so that they have
some sort of intuition about the proper
way to employ it uh or that we wouldn't
want to do it um or they might be more
hesitant about the way it's way it's
used so let's not call causality out of
this and I only showed US presidents on
here notice I I should point out that of
the presidents that are in the data set
every single one of them except for
Garfield
uh was categorized as having been a
wartime president so that probably says
a little bit more about our country than
it does about the presidents uh in
charge of it that we just happen to be
at conflict a lot
um I appreciate the time um I was afraid
this might last uh I might run out of
slides but it looks like I didn't if you
have questions I'm happy to talk about
it Jared thanks for the opportunity um I
appreciate it thank you
all